let me ask you a question joe yeah
you're right here with me
yeah have you been on the floor of the
senate
you were in the center for a few years
yeah time and time again
talking about the necessity with pride
about cutting social security
cutting medicare cutting veterans
programs no you never said that
no when i argued if we should freeze
federal spending
i meant social security as well i meant
medicare and medicaid
i'm not veterans men i'm at every single
solitary thing
in the government look here's the door
honest guy
why don't you just tell the truth here
we all make mistakes i am telling the
truth and i not only tried it once
i tried it twice i tried it the third
time and i tried it a fourth time
joe let me repeat it again i want you
just to
be straight with the american people i
am saying
that you have been on the floor of the
senate
time and time again talking about the
need
to cut social security medicare and
veterans programs is that true or is
that no it's not true
that is not true that is not true i'm
not veterans man i'm at
every single solitary thing in the
government
everything was on the table i did not
support any of those cuts
in social security or in veterans oh
whoa whoa
you everything was on the table all
right you're right you just said it
including in your judgment cuts the
social security and veterans
in order to get the kinds of changes we
need on
other things related joel thinks but but
we did not cut it
i know because people like me helped
stop that all that i would say
to the american people go to youtube
it's all over the place
joe said it many many times i'm
surprised you know you can defend that
or change your mind on it but you can't
deny
get on bernie feeling the burn
[Laughter]
five more days people five more days
thanks god
five more days welcome to the show my
name is wayne dupree and you are
watching the wayne dupree show
off to my left your right is leah blue
eyes bella leo what's going on
hey share the show
make sure you share the show and shout
out from the missouri watch party going
on
in facebook we got a watch party in here
today yeah we got a watch party going on
um it's raining like cats and dogs out
there
it is you got it too liam yeah
i got water in my basement whoa
yeah yeah my dog
had to go to the bathroom she's staying
in the house you know brian
brian is the bishop so he can probably
be holding baptisms down there
because my mother's full of grace get me
out of this place
yeah all right ladies and gentlemen we
are
we're um five days away from the
presidential election a lot
a lot of stuff going on a lot of yeah
shenanigans
it starts with an ass you got it half
right
a lot of [ __ ] mannequins going on
democrats ain't playing around are they
the democrats they playing around
they're not they're out for i mean
they you know how stupid we say the
democrats are
they are running some way behind the
scenes
they're maniacal they're mf5 i
mi5 stuff man they are
ghcq yeah
i mean they are listening in on tucker
carlson's phone calls
and
[Laughter]
stopping the package mid flight you
taking his stuff out
there's something stuff
they got like cameras in their shoes
they've got messages that self-destruct
in 10 seconds
covering tracks that come with tracks
inspector gadget stuff
his niece penny got involved they got
the dog
the helicopter they're flying over fedex
with the helicopter hat
if y'all if y'all don't know what we're
talking about
uh last night tucker carlson got on his
show and
um he talked about that they had
some document well he was told about
some documents he reached out to his
producer in new york
he did reach out to his producer from
new york and
for some um they got they were supposed
to get some documents overnighted to him
and wherever he was uh the documents
were
removed in mid-flight
and it was an insured package too oh
yes oh the company the corporation has
launched their own internal
investigation because this money's being
due
they said the last time we saw it was 3
a.m when the package was
was discovered by a fedex employee and
it was ripped open
and nothing was inside nothing was
inside it's like a sherlock holmes
mystery
and and you know what the the
look the best comedians i think are on
social media i'm so they are
on social media y'all we're like y'all
clowning
because the left don't care it's the
people on the right the people on the
right was like
you know oh really the dog ate the
homework type stuff really
seriously yes we were talking about that
too how this
carlson loses all credibility here yeah
i
if i was him honestly i'm going to try
to kept this secret
that's what i thought too right i don't
even say this out loud
i mean why yeah yeah did you notice one
big key fact that he forgot to mention
whether or not he made copies yeah he
never once said
but don't worry because we made copies
he didn't say it
he sure didn't he sure didn't as a
matter of fact let me
let me get that up here so that y'all
can see exactly there's a lot going on
uh that we don't have time to get to on
the air but there's something specific
going on behind the scenes right now
that we
did feel we should tell you about so on
monday of this week we received a
from a source a collection of
confidential documents related to the
biden family
we believe those documents are authentic
they're real and they're damning
at the time we received them our my
executive producer justin wells and i
were in los
angeles preparing to interview tony
babalinsky about the biden's business
dealings in china ukraine and other
countries
so we texted a producer in new york and
we asked him to send those documents to
us
in la and he did that so monday
afternoon of this week he shipped those
documents
overnight to california with a large
national carrier brand name company
that we've used you've used countless
times with never a single problem
but the biden documents never arrived in
los angeles
tuesday morning we received word from
the shipping company that our package
had been
opened and the contents were missing the
documents had disappeared
now to its credit the company took this
very seriously and immediately began a
search
they traced the envelope from the moment
our producers dropped it off
in manhattan on monday all the way to 3
44 am yesterday morning that's when an
employee at a sorting facility in
another state
noticed that our package was open and
empty
apparently it had been opened so the
company's security team
interviewed every one of its employees
who touched the envelope we sent
they searched the plane and the trucks
that carried it they went through the
office in new york where our producer
dropped that package off they combed the
entire
cavernous sorting facility they used
pictures of what we had sent
so that searchers would know what to
look for they went far and beyond
but they found nothing those documents
have vanished
as of tonight the company has no idea
and no working theory even
about what happened to this trove of
materials documents that are directly
relevant to the presidential campaign
just six days from now we spoke to
executives at that company a few hours
ago
they seemed baffled and deeply bothered
by this
and so are we
after break we'll have more information
about joe biden's business dealings
around the world they were very
[Laughter]
the employee that got away with it
somebody walked up to him later
on and hit him with a forgive me stick
so he couldn't remember what he did well
you know maybe they're paying off an
employee kind of like how they did
i don't know it's somewhere in
california it's 5 000 no it's fifty five
thousand dollars or so or fifty five
thousand votes for five thousand dollars
if you can get
them to switch so maybe somebody said
here i'll give you five grand
please step out of this package but come
on you didn't make copies
he doesn't mention anywhere in there
about coffee well if it has anything to
do with
bobalinski's stuff bob lindsay's got
multiple copies on everything
i don't know well if it would be blah
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
copies
yeah but wouldn't you he was with
bobolinsky so therefore the documents
wouldn't have been
about bobolinsky or it was about
anything else
right he he was with me he wouldn't even
need the documents that bobolinsky had
copies on top of copies right because
that's who he was with
this just hype tech i'm just saying
that's not where uh oh bobby lives
though right
he flew into nevada he was with him
in l.a uh and what i'm trying to say is
he
alluded to the fact that these were
other different breaking news
information copies they were dabbing
even though he didn't make any copies
and here's the thing if you know they're
damning why would you send them the
entire way across country
considering considering tucker you're
the one who told us do not trust
mail and ballots but yet you're gonna
mail over to california
you just told us not to mail on our damn
ballot but you mailed those top secrets
how does that make sense you did exactly
what you told us not to do
[Laughter]
and he was like well yeah you know we
use a service that you
that you all use and we use all together
you know we all use it
we've never had a problem you know don't
mail on your ballots
but we all use this we never had
problems that was good
that was good oh why again
many many of y'all made some great
statements last night
and um now i do know some
some people some people either well all
right you know what whatever i'm
throwing up the ghost on this thing this
this is just too stupid i mean you know
they were this is just too stupid
how do you not scan it into your
computer and email it
what you can easily create
because i know fox news probably they
have to have a private server somewhere
a private server that is covered that is
super covered that
that hillary hasn't touched yeah double
double vpn stuff
right right right that he could have
just logged on and looked at it you
didn't need he didn't need to mail it
he was coming back the next day he
couldn't wait eight hours longer
he was coming back the next day no
no no don't say that
is that for real well he said they were
mailed out to me
and then he's he comes home the next day
and does the show from his
from his normal place in new york yeah
this is dumb oh my this makes him look
like such a tool
he was coming back the next day he was
coming back right
he was coming back he just wanted it he
just want he just wanted the documents
there with him i guess
so ladies and gentlemen and and then we
find out today
this morning that the hacker
from hackers oh 2.3 million
from wisconsin yeah trump campaign
missing missing some change not as much
as
uh on bradley stove not as much as he
stole got uh
uh absconded with
that was 10 no i think 40 million did he
walk away like 40 million
i don't know if they can pay the event
centers now
they'll move it around they'll make it
right but if you can let me finish i
watch today and him saying
if you could please donate we've got
this covered we've got this covered with
the event centers but to help us pay for
these
event centers he literally said that
word for word today please donate to
wisconsin
gop or whatever i'm serious so
hackers are whatever
you know what whatever how do you get
2.3 mil
that almost had to be an inside job you
don't st you look
look you you might steal 200 000
you might steal like maybe even
500 000 you know
but when you start getting up to 2.33
million
something on your phone should register
your money your
somebody's trying to get into your
account okay
my bank wonders yes my bank once alerted
me
that there was a strange purchase from
arby's because i don't eat fast food
so they wanted to deny the purchase
because they have never seen me purchase
fast food before so if they can do that
surely aren't they alerting somebody
that 2.3 million dollars has disappeared
not only that but after 999
999 once you get to the 10 000 mark
when you withdraw that money you got to
report that to the fbi
the bank you mean not the truth you
can't just walk out with 10 grand that's
just not possible i mean
exactly right right anything anything
over 10
grand somebody's got to do something
right yeah
withdrew twelve thousand dollars one
time and that was
an ordeal that i didn't oh really seeing
45 minutes i deposited 20 i i called my
bank and i said look i want to deposit
money
i can deposit this much but i don't want
all these alerts and vowels to go off
and they said no go ahead and deposit
whatever you want we got to report over
anything over 10 grand so i just
deposited the whole thing right
because they were reporting it anyway
try and get it back out
i'm just saying how do you i can i
believe in 3 million
yeah and now hackers are saying now the
fbi is saying
hospitals have to be worried they're
ready to attack hospitals and
mess up their information system so
they're afraid our hospitals are going
to go down
who china i mean i mean i don't know
hackers it said
it says the state or something
department just came out or that guy
just came out and warned all hospitals
across america to be on alert
because they are being hacked and
they're trying to take down the entire
information system
oops
you know what the um and you know the um
our government will probably try to
blame this on albanian since
they don't want to bring in china for
anything so
you know albanian hackers albania
yeah it's in romania it used to be
nigeria
but not anymore they're they're out of
romania norway hackers
you don't know norwegian actors
this that sounds like a special kind of
donut right
sorry norway i'm not cracking on anybody
in norway
greenland greenland hackers maybe
maybe living out in isolation because
they're not going to blame
anything on china then they're not going
to blame truckers documents on china
they're not going to blame uh the
coronavirus on china
oh no no can't do that that one came
from iran
the coroner virus came from iran don't
you they're called
according to the democrat oh european
virus
yeah look ladies and gentlemen
when something stinks we gotta call it
out because if not it's just gonna
continue to stink and it stinks
so that you know when i watched that
last night i was just like
i don't i literally don't know what to
say here there was just so many
questions and then he just kind of went
and that is all now
tony bevelinski on and i'm like how are
you just going to leave it
like that i don't know this you know
let's assume he didn't say the name of
the carrier um
no i
you think it was amazon no no no no no
they don't do that kind of shipping
oh yeah i know you're disappointed i
used to work
uh as a contractor for fedex for one of
their buildings out in lax
i had some pretty extensive knowledge of
their systems
and their security cameras everywhere
um millions of packages going through
there during christmas time
and it was insanity to even think that
you could keep track of something in
there
but they did and they could and they're
really really good with it
um how they don't got the guy
on camera to pitch something
of this package disappearing it's an
inside job
well you know why because
ft didn't kill himself
because the dims did such a great job in
splicing
it goes from 1203 to 1204
trouble five 12 10 yeah
11 12 12. you know you know they just
slice that part out of there
overnight overnight
[Music]
whatever man whatever i mean
and and you can't say that
you can't be do y'all think they shipped
their originals
i would hope not but i mean because
seriously why why even report it if it
was
copies if you have the original back at
home
because you don't
[Laughter]
right right yeah you don't report the
copies were stolen copies
tucker and even and look and even
and even if it was okay
so let's just say for stupidity state
let's just say
that they did chip in the original and
make copies
those copies are now deemed uh
[Music]
um questionable
because they're not original because
they're not original right
yep i think tucker got all excited he
had 7.5 million people watching his show
the night before
and uh he just wanted to one-up himself
he's like well we we hit 45
45 million viewers 45
look look hey take that let's see
let's fedex the documentary
you can tell he was kind of like okay
thanks tucker like he didn't even want
to get into it with them when they split
it
when they split the next show is this
the
wisconsin
[Laughter]
michael blue blade it's on the way
okay oh turn the cameras off
oh right right
what a turn of events in the last 12
hours
12 to 24 hours
tigers documents
[Laughter]
him we got him right here
we didn't we didn't use fedex we used
a real carrier that we knew that would
get the documents
yeah here let me let me pass them on
over okay
there you go now they're going away
thank you and nothing got lost
nothing got lost you shouldn't you
should have used
wayne leah
[Laughter]
so sad um
yeah so um okay so
we're five days away from the
presidential uh election
i i mean i just i just thought that
those
those two stories were stupid
[Laughter]
and i mean we were on jeffrey two look
we we
equal opportunity we were on jeffrey two
jeffrey toobin last week and then we're
on tucker
we're gonna make fun of somebody
everybody yeah everybody
anybody
there is a um there's a lot of noise
going on
out there but one thing that we did find
out last night
and let me let me just bring this up
here right now
one thing that we found out last night
and we have been talking
we we've been going back and forth
because um
i remember hearing that many felt that
amy
coney barrett going up to the supreme
court getting sworn in
would help a couple of the cases that
were up
for um review regarding the ballots
being
counted after the election um up in
wisconsin
they are what the hell's up with
wisconsin they
they said that the ballots have to be
counted by election day right
yeah they they ruled against whatever
their governor said
scout the scales came and said nope yeah
they said a judge can't make law
basically
they said judge can't make law we lost
we look we lost oh hell no
how much 2.3 no
we going to take 2.3 million
he won't let us count votes big paul
said wisconsin is so cheesy
it actually kind of makes sense here
we'll get them back we gotta see he's
full of holes
i understand why atp didn't she can't
rule on anything right just yet because
they said she has to
make herself aware of the case she
didn't have enough time to learn about
it which i talked about last week that's
what i was afraid of now pennsylvania's
really rude
because they said look we'll split the
ballots we'll make sure that the ballots
that are being sent in
are separate from those that are going
in but we can't rule on it until
afterwards so
somebody somebody on twitter said that
uh wisconsin got
par scaled um
like the new f word all right holy cow
north carolina north carolina see and
i told i told leah and brian because
i thought when the supreme court sets a
preschool
for you crazy stop laughing um i'll get
serious here bro
sorry when when the supreme court sets a
precedent
they usually go along with that
precedent so i thought
what happened in what happened in
wisconsin
would carry over to uh michigan uh north
carolina and pennsylvania
yeah thanks for giving me that hope lane
yeah i did i thought you know i gave her
to hope but uh
north carolina the supreme court is
going to allow
north carolina to receive ballots
absentee ballots up
until nine days
and they said they said the postage
stamp
it doesn't even matter if it's unlegible
they're going to
yeah they're going to take it as long as
those nine days right right even if the
postage is
it uh unlegible like they don't know
what what it was postmarked
even if it's unlegible we're still gonna
take do you know what that and you know
what that means
that means if trump has a big lead that
these democrats that didn't vote can
hurry up and come out and panic if
they're already registered grab some
voting
and mail it in to try to make sure their
candidate wins honestly that's what
they're trying to tell us yeah
big paul said it best election day ends
when trump loses
yeah yeah basically yeah uh
well he's gonna blow it out the water on
on election night he has to
and that's and that's why we keep saying
or that's why we keep saying what we
need
we have to win right and we have to win
without north carolina and pennsylvania
we have to yeah
we have to figure out a way and the
reason why leah says pennsylvania is
because
it works great also yesterday the
supreme court
also refused to schedule fast-track
review of mail-in ballots from being
counted in pennsylvania if they arrive
after election day that's two states
that's two battleground states
yeah yeah pennsylvania being the biggest
battleground out of them yeah
this is shameful i'm with angel chorus
um a lot of this right now it's just a
lot of noise
and and trump is definitely gonna win
big in my personal opinion and some of
the polls and the numbers i've looked at
and now we're getting reports coming out
wayne 31
black vote brian brian
don't even do that wait i'll tell you
it's being reported man
i got the reports but it's also being
reported
they're good guys no they aren't not
internet
oh it's right it's raining cats and dogs
really raining cats and dogs
my thing is though you if you're gonna
believe that pool brian then you have to
believe that
the young people goes up in all the
other polls remember we don't believe in
polls so for you to tell a poll kind of
disappoints me
no it's i absolutely
i have to say it because it's so
ridiculous
look at her face look at should like so
i mean we don't believe in polls you
can't say you do
rasmus rasmussen reports
says that 27
30 30 31
those are the daily pulse of black
voters
for trump they said they're hitting 31
and they're also saying 100 1.6 million
young voters came out to vote that's a
lot of young voters this year
yeah but 31 percent black total trounce
that
not if they're only talking about 100
people
guys i'm i'm laughing because i'm not
buying it
and i know i know i know but but it's
the if he could get
people out there there are some people
out there that believe that mess though
if he can get 19 it's gonna be a huge
it'll be a huge day huge debt i think 19
is doable
trump is getting anywhere how much how
much did he get in 2016.
seven six eight i thought six
i thought it was seven seven six or
seven i'm gonna act like you know that
all too
yeah no
you're so curious with holes why aren't
you on fox always right now
it's 31. he thinks he's raymond over
here memorizing all these numbers
[Laughter]
it's amazing to me you think he's
ringing man 8.235
there you go somewhat a couple weeks ago
somebody gave me the
well i don't know if it was the internal
numbers of black voters
for trump but it was between and it and
it changed my view because i thought he
would be getting
between eight and nine they said that he
would get between eight and eleven
not thirty something right i mean
look trump is good but he hasn't worked
that good
i mean that that's no no i'm because
because the country you know why because
the country has been split too much on
this racist stuff yeah that's why
if the if the racist thing was not there
yes
yes 30 45 yes
but there's a whole and and but that
racist stigma
is out there and it's out there and
as a brilliant trump he doesn't he he
feels he doesn't have to address it
i'm not going to address it i've done
this and i've done that and i've done
that move on
so what that does that lead that
seriously it does it leaves
a type of thought in people's head i
mean that
you caught the little kid down the
street there's a family down the street
that my kids play with
a little black kid i think he's like 10
or 11.
scratch the trump bumper sticker off my
truck i had to replace it with a nicer
one and a bigger one
so that's okay i showed a kid
he said trump's a racist he's with the
ku klux klan i looked at him i said
the kkk come here son let me show you
something
so i pulled the pictures up i said look
there's trump with tyson there's trump
with all these other black folks is that
trump dated a black woman and the kid
looked at me confused
walked away like a week later i mean
he's like he's still a racist angel
courses
come on guys just wait you'll see many
blacks are waking up
many blacks are waking up
oh come on angel take it easy girl
why because yeah
yeah yeah you didn't know blexit and
exodus both of them hand-in-hand
making movements oh speaking of that
i saw another walk away billboard sign
on the west side of cincinnati on
the road i told brandon the road i told
brandon that
you know we gave him a shout out for the
show i i did i told him that we gave him
a shout out for the show
because um of all the
organizations that really were
grassroots
his his was the one that made
uh the bigger difference out there
because
he's spent time in every state i mean
he's been the most uh
active yeah active actor right
uh if now if scott pressler was an
organization by himself scott pressler
would
be up there i mean well he is up there
but uh
he's doing it for another reason he's
in a different capacity right right but
uh
if you're talking about bringing over
voters uh
that that heavyweight title goes to
brandon for right now
uh but um jeremy says from eight percent
vote to 30 33 is awesome
yeah okay if if that happens i
you know what we got to we got to make
up something we got to make up something
that i would do
if um if it is 33 percent
you have to dress like nancy pelosi for
a whole show no no no no
you're drunk yeah
if it is if it's 30
and above i
i don't know what i'll do i i it's just
inconceivable
that just doesn't even
pause it paul says kanye will help more
blex it and walk away
listen come on paul you're writing a lot
of crazy stuff today in the chat bro
yeah oh fun you drinking my friend
drinking your lunch notice i don't say
much about this subject because it's all
it's all just opinion at this point we
have no proof of any
no we don't actually oh it's just kind
of like okay well
you know when it comes to
uh when it comes to
uh the the rasmussen thing
the reason why the reason why we don't
talk polls that much on this show
is because it's a snapshot but it's only
talking to a certain amount of people
those certain amount of people do not
speak
for a whole big
a lot of people it speaks for those
people that are taking a poll
so words matter like we were like we've
said on the show many times where
words matter so when you talk about
polls you have to say
of the people poll right these are what
the numbers are
but uh what the media with sean hannity
and them do
they get up there and says america says
this or or america voted and
no american didn't vote america didn't
take no politics
you know they're saying oh texas is a
swing state now
texas really if so joe would be there
and kamala would be there just going
nuts obama you'd see him
sweating armpits and all just bashing on
from you don't see them anywhere near
texas because they know they don't have
a chance right so and that's where the
pools
you can't believe them that's why i
don't believe any single pool i see
you can't you can only believe facts of
what have happened
lastly what about yeah what about the
phone calls that weren't picked up
what about the phone calls the people
who cried
i can tell you everybody i know
you know i'm in a lot of trump groups i
will tell you that on facebook because i
like to get the feel for what's going on
and so many of them just got called by
polling people
told them that i was for joe they just
messed with them don't these pollsters
get it by now they hate the pollsters
they're going to tell you joe just to
mess with you yes angel chorus
i pray every single day for this country
i pray for the safety of the president
and for the direction and the future of
this country
um so absolutely prayer warriors
don't worry about it god's got there's
two outcomes
and god knows which one's gonna happen
if joe biden wins
america you deserve to be punished
says it the bible okay if joe biden will
lie we're gonna be punished it's gonna
happen you deserve if trump wins
america will be better off and we
deserve it
that's it that's that simple
don't worry what did jesus say about the
polling numbers
he said
those polls come from the dark side
there you go
check this out check this out let me
then let me give a little amendment to
that thing
because if biden wins uh
it's god's will and if trump wins is
god's will you know why
because he's already set things in
motion
the thing is whatever happens on tuesday
that's the way it was supposed to happen
and what happens afterwards
that's the way it's supposed to happen
and how you deal with it
god that's how god is looking at it
uh we're all
we all go through temptation and trials
in our life god puts us through these
things
to build our character and to make us
stronger
there's a whole lot of there's a whole
lot of people out there right now that
have taken a whole lot of things for
granted
um on both sides we don't know who's
right
well actually we sort of know who's
right and who's wrong because of the way
that we
have been brought up but in this day and
time and i know that my co-host
will agree with me in this day and time
things have been turned on the head
right right it's wrong and wrong is
right
not not that we believe that but that's
just the way
things have been pushed out through the
meeting right is wrong and wrong is
right
peop people like joe biden nance pelosi
peter strzok
uh uh uh all those people
like should have gotten some type of
criminal
sentence yeah he did not they did not
right and there's a whole lot of stuff
out there that is
pushing all all of us to
to want to believe that joe biden is
um that hunter and joe is is um gonna
see some jail time tonight
they're not gonna they're not um
i said there's three tiers of justice
bro and and
uh the reason why i say it's three brian
uh
and this is our inside thing the reason
why i say is three
is because you got rich you got your
politicians and then you got us
yeah because if this was anybody else
with the hundred bud in case he'd
already be in handcuffs
right when he's already here brian brian
what you know what bro
brian would be like this yeah
gone you know what completely un-person
completely would be in the same place
that tucker carlson's documents are
there i mean when you talk about rich
the uber rich i mean that's how epstein
got away with what he got away with for
so long yeah
i mean i mean it is what you
like right and like i tried to tell you
brian
i was telling brian in the chat um our
private chat
you'd be amazed at what people will do
for money people will do a lot of things
for money
i'm shocked at what people do for such
little money
oh people do a lot of things
hey not to change the subject but did
you see governor cuomo dismissed his
nursing home scandal
he said it was a conspiracy on the view
and blames trump for all the kova deaths
said it was a conspiracy the the death
of the nursing home
karma should bite him in the oh and
trump should win new york just because
of him
isn't that terrible to win new york
because of cuomo
that literally might be the most sinful
thing i have heard all year
out of somebody's mouth that the nursing
home was a conspiracy
see see that's what i'm talking about
there's so many people that
need to uh walk
that need to meet the gunner's daughter
basically and
uh they just keep getting away
with doing this and then you look to the
people of the state
why can't y'all just vote his ugly ass
out of office
stop giving this man political power if
i mean y'all have been locked down
i'm still surprised i am i'm still
surprised
that some places in america are still
locked down
yeah new york city the restaurants they
said almost close to
45 50 percent of restaurants will never
open again in new york city
because of this what yeah they can't
they can't open up close to 50
they can never open again they've
destroyed it
guys this is america they're destroying
people's businesses and como's saying
that
now the nursing home's conspiracy i'm
just glad i'm not in new york city
i saw a camera on the outside of new
york
right now outside of new york city in
new york city but
it was showing outside it still looks
like a ghost town
it's still like a ghost town in new york
on time
in times square you really don't see it
booming walking
oh no not at all you know so new york
does not have
gubernatorial um term limits and the
governor
cuomo is seeking a fourth
term in 2022.
it says it don't this is uh by wikipedia
i'm just saying
it says that he's seeking a fourth term
in 2022.
new york
because he isn't good enough for
anything else
what would he get a job doing right
right right
um i mean except for going down to that
main island that barack obama was
went after he after he left well maybe
him and his brother can do stand-up with
q-tips like they did
right during when everybody was dying in
the nursing homes like a bunch of idiots
that's shameful uh we
we had the latest number well actually
it's probably a little bit more than
that
thousand early votes whoo baby
a million anytime you know 76 million
million
million six million i'm sorry 76 million
early votes um
and with 41 outstanding
41 million are outstanding 76 have been
76 million have been sent in already 135
million people
i can't i mean i have to let y'all know
this
135 136 million people voted in 2016.
the young people and minorities are
voting in this election
they didn't vote in 2016. i warned
everybody yesterday about the young
people
ages 18 to 25 and i'm and i'm telling
you
they're the ones that were out for the
blm marches they were the ones out
riding
these people are angry and uh like
brian said well you know they were paid
to march and
and to riot yeah well they can also be
paid to vote and if the money's right
they're going to vote joe
doesn't need to be much money either we
see this right oh yeah college kids will
do
anything for me 25 bucks i mean we all
know this
they'd sign up for for credit cards and
get a free t-shirt
they would my question is is there more
18 to 25 year old radicalized
crazy liberals that are now voting this
year new or are there
are is the trump base big enough to take
them on that's
what i'm trying to say normally young
people
don't sway elections they haven't in the
past because they don't all come out
but this year is different they're not
partying in bars at night they're not
really studying for midterms
because you can't it's coveted what else
do they have to do
this is their hey guys instead of all
piling together
and going to the football game in
college and watching the football game
this is like their thing to do because
there's nothing else to do
so does this make the lazy um liberal
college kids come out covet and if so
we might have an issue on our hands
that's all i'm just sounding the alarm
i'm i'm concerned
i am because i knew the numbers and i'm
not
see look right there here is um
this came out from los angeles this
morning
said that more than 6.8 million
people ages 18 to 29 have voted early
or by mail two and a half fold increase
over their voting level
at this point from four years ago this
is the first time i'm reading this
and this is exactly what i'm talking
about right
l.a times came out with that today
somebody said i don't think they're into
football you wouldn't believe
how many uh college kids go to their
college football games
it is insane yeah i'm not sure from
my college team yeah julian tina i think
her name is i don't
believe they're in the football oh my
gosh the college kids love going to
their
college football games i mean look at
penn state they can fill that place
but they can't go to the alcohol it is
the after party but see they can't go to
it this year so
you know right so i'm saying they're not
they're bored they can't go to bars bars
close at 11. what else they have to do
they're going to go vote and
unfortunately the reason why their bars
and schools are closed
is because the democrats they don't get
it they're still going to vote joe
because that's what they've been
told to do they're like zombies and that
is what i'm worried about
yeah i think a lot of them will vote
trump
okay you we just complained on this show
five weeks ago how all these liberal
colleges
are indoctrinating these kids and and
brainwashing them to believe that
communism is the way to go
and then you're gonna say there oh i
think i'm gonna vote trump when you just
said
that colleges need to literally be
ripped down and rebuilt
because of what's going on in them
remember yeah they've been taken over by
marxists yeah
that's what i'm worried about yep that's
what i'm worried about
i'm that is what my biggest concern is
i'm not worried about the elderly vote
i think they're going to stick with
trump i know some might have gone with
joe that's fine
i'm not worried about the minority vote
i think that they're pro-trump i really
do a lot of them
i'm not worried about that i'm worried
about these 18 to 25.
i got questions about that one that's
fine but i don't think that that's what
can sway this election
i think it's the younger i think it's 18
to 25 year olds
well i mean i i tell you another thing
that can sway
the election real huge is the latino
vote which is
[Music]
i've read many reports where the
democrat and see we all kept thinking
that look that latinos would would go
for
the democrats because you know you know
immigrant type stuff and everything
they are conservative from at their core
okay they are concerned at their court
and they
have been more uh uh
they have been more pushed than were not
pushed
they've been more directed toward
president trump
and republicans actually uh then
uh then a whole lot more but you know we
also talked about that
um solid majority yesterday too
how uh a lot of people out there are
silent
uh and what i heard that uh republicans
outnumbered
democrats by 300 000 yes that is correct
um that gives us some hope you're right
lisa i think lisa clark
is right uh what she's saying in the
chat um yeah they outnumbered them so
that's our hope
that's our hope wayne i agree with you
there we have to double
that 300 000 right on election day we
have to at least
go up 600 or 700 000 over to democrats
because
we don't know what is up with early
voting we don't
i mean you know we can pick and pry and
and hope and wish and faith and pray
spit um fast and all that stuff uh
but we don't know what the early vote is
you know yeah we can go back and say
well this is what we used to do in
history so
okay but this is 2020 2020.
this is this is crazy stuff i mean covet
there's already state and local leaders
already ordering new restrictions
okay also coronavirus surge
also
i'm seeing it i'm going to people's
homes now
and people are more scared now than
they've ever been before about kovid
and it's almost every person
but it just happened this this past week
well here's the thing with us they're
blaming this on trump because he's
opening up stuff too quickly they say
that's why the coronavirus surge is
happening that's actually not why it's
happening
does anybody know why it's actually
happening has anybody done the research
here's why well a scientist just found
out
that europe's second wave remember we're
normally six weeks behind europe
the reason why europe's second wave is
hitting so hard
is because the virus mutated just a
little itty bitty bit
and it's just becoming a little bit more
contagious it's not becoming deadlier
the protein spike is just getting a
little bit spikier i guess you could say
in layman's terms
so it's going to be more contagious and
i wish trump would get on the stage and
say hey look it's not my fault
it's not because we're opening too
quickly it's just because this virus
just every so often gets a little bit
more contagious
that's all it has nothing to do with
trump it has to do with how the virus
goes
this is how pandemics work viruses can
get more contagious they can get more
deadlier thank god
this is not showing any signs of forming
into a deadlier
type but it is showing that it's
becoming a little bit more contagious
then you bring the cold weather in and
all of us crammed together
small areas of course people are going
to have it more so headlines shouldn't
read
trump coronavirus gets worse because of
him it should read
temperatures are falling viruses spread
quicker in the cold and we're all going
to be jammed together
in in closer indoor spaces so expect
cases to rise
that's how it should look but the media
won't tell you that
flew this past year lowest ever in
decades
over time so we don't have the flu no
more
no more flu they just switched it
made that's all coveted well i mean
you know with the flu they got that
which i don't take but i don't
what i don't understand is aren't they
still doing
flu swabs so why would it change
anything
if they're doing a flu what i say are
they doing flu swaps
well that's what i'm saying if they are
why aren't the reports in
i i haven't seen it that's what i'm
questioning everybody's like well the
flu's lower this year well are they
actually doing the swabs
i don't even think they're testing for
it that's on track of it
yeah hilly said no flu swabs
i didn't think there were because
they're using them all for covid hi
haley
isn't that amazing
cdc stopped tracking the flu who was
that last
oh that was oh nevermind i won't bring
her
i just sidestepped the land mine holy
crap
i was looking at you
no you gonna say it he's gonna say it oh
the cdc has not
stopped testing for flute even though
some conservative people have
put it in their timelines fake
i think they did i mean if you want a
flu test you can get one but i just
think they might
not be swabbing as much yeah because
they're doing the coven
you know you know um again i've
and i really feel bad i mean i okay two
things i really feel bad
for the airport industry i i really do
now
on the flip side i'm kind of i feel good
because
you know you can walk through the
airport and it's not
going to the shelter you know and you
sit down and relax
and you know you're like yeah this is
good you know
because i can get used to that it's
really yeah give me a hot towel
yeah it's sleep here i mean it's clean
and you don't have a whole lot of people
around but
for the airport industry it's bad
it's really bad um
american airlines have anybody on it
american airlines is cutting all their
flights and jamming everybody in like
sardines
there were three flights to florida they
canceled two of them
put us all in one craft then you
they canceled them all and then put us
on a flight
with a layover i feel bad for the cruise
industry too
i do i mean i just can't i can't even
fathom them coming back
because you can't shove everybody on a
cruise ship you know that that's where
most viruses do break out you're always
hearing about how all these people got
sick on a cruise ship
and then you're gonna send them to sea
in the middle of nowhere
to get covered and then you're stranded
out there because they don't want you
back on
on main land because then you'll give it
to everybody remember what happened last
time a lot of cruisers are saying
no i don't want to do this i and i just
don't know where that industry
what's going to happen i hope they have
a lot of money in savings
yeah i mean we have to
and i i know maybe a whole lot of y'all
haven't really thought about it
okay up and this is brother wayne
talking to you right now
his brother wayne sister leah and the
brother reverend pastor deacon doctor
uh rain man yeah but um
sooner or later you're going to have to
realize
things aren't going back to what it was
before 2020
it's not we're the only way you're going
to get that back is
in your own mind we are going to have to
adapt
and build on what we have right now
because
everything has been hit and roughed up
and i mean
with the leaders finding out that they
have a little bit more power than what
they knew that they had they can shut
down the whole state
for fake viruses in the future if they
wanted to
yeah make you wear masks they can keep
you in your house
for fake stuff if they really wanted to
yeah i know i know
y'all can leave and cause issues and
stuff like that
and then get your head cracked open with
one of those billy cru
clubs or tear gas and and whatnot and
then you'll be on
um some of these conservative timelines
uh with your video and y'all getting
beat up but
things have changed and we have to adapt
or and learn how to become victors over
all this mess
because if not nobody's to listen to a
a whole bunch of cry babies tonight okay
so trump wins
and trump still doesn't have the power
that he doesn't have now i'm
sympathizing with you angela
angel course i'm sympathizing with you
however
trump couldn't change it now when he
wins
he still doesn't have the power to
change tomorrow he needs
he needs a strong house
and yup that's why trump has been saying
y'all have to
vote down republican now we don't preach
that here on the show
but it's very important that he gets a
down ticket republican
and hope we got to hope and pray that
some of those republicans
that are down ticket are real
conservatives that really want to help
do what president trump wants to do
because the people that were there
before
were were bottlenecks you know they
they got and got the hell out
you know wayne i hope all this i hope
this has opened up their eyes and hope
this scared them enough to know
that they've got to do something or
they're going to lose everything that's
right
that's right i mean and it's not and
it's not negative talk
it's real talk you you can't
you can't go through this life thinking
that just because president trump is
president
everything's going to be fine because if
you looked over the last couple years it
has not been
he's been trying his best to do
everything that he can do with did
with the amount of power that he's had
and and what and what has nancy pelosi
tried to do she's tried to rule over him
from the beginning
uh schumer has tried to rule over him
the media uh and and their republican
buddies
have tried to think of all the people
that have come
out on the other side of this election
president trump wins think of all the
republicans that have publicly come out
and supported joe biden yeah
publicly publicly yeah and
and and and and then you have them you
have two democrats still you got your
media
now it's almost like caesar by himself
now yes he does has uh uh uh the supreme
court
he does have his for oh and another
thing
roberts sided with the liberals last
night for uh
the north carolina and pennsylvania
thing yeah robertson
so he has us a slight
uh advantage in the supreme court with
the people that he put up there
but for the most part and and and then
he has a couple of senators he doesn't
have
a super a lot but he has a couple
senators that he can lean on
he has a couple of house members he can
lena
and it and again you have
all these people again it's like caesar
uh and i'm not calling him a tyrant or
or uh what a dictator i'm not calling
him a dictator i'm just saying
that not only do you have to vote for
him
and vote uh well not vote a lot but you
know what i'm saying
y'all got to pray like y'all ain't never
prayed before
if you haven't talked to god in the last
20 years start tonight
and catch up and say that things are
going to be changing
in the near future i ain't playing
no you know i'm sorry brian
i don't play like that man and you know
i mean i'm sick and tired of
people and and this fake this uh
this uh fake
attitude that everything is is is
is is gonna be good just because one
person is up there that person needs
help
that person needs help he needs
an entire crew to do what you guys want
him to do
and i know it's gonna be tough if you
live in kentucky
i know that you you've seen all these
ads for amy mcgrath
you know she's younger she's up and
coming she's no aoc
but she's giving mitch a run for his
his money right now and if if mitch
loses his job you kiss it all goodbye
i'm sorry if mitch loses
that that's it that's it you just
the next two years are gonna be as bad
as the last two years
if you think that say we keep the house
and we lose the senate
hit pump the brakes that's it it's done
you know what and i'm and i'm sorry to
say
if they keep the house and we lose the
senate
don't get mad with president trump if he
changes
how he governs a little bit
don't yeah he'll have to he has to adapt
to that then yeah he'll death
he'll have to have to right he has to
and if you want to get mad at anybody
you get mad yourself
because many people have been using
these social media platforms thinking
that
they're super activists and that they're
making all these changes in the whole
world
you just tweeting and you're not i mean
if you're not on the ground
making change not hey i want to talk to
you about uh
you know your community and stuff like
that hey let's go to a community council
meeting hey i'm running for community
council hey
if you ain't doing all that and you just
on twitter
y'all need to change what y'all think
[Music]
let me see how many retweets i get
is not doom and gloom it's truth
you know
truth truth is president trump
is trying his best to be the best leader
that he can be for this country
you can't try any harder i can tell you
that right right
i mean he dude his the dude has crammed
almost eight years worth of stuff in the
three and a half
yeah that's helped him do that now he
did it legally so for
marty marty blue is on the chat room
guys
i know he's nuts and he's really really
really out there but when he says how is
trump
not a totalitarian in your eyes
because trump follows the
rules he's allowed to nominate judges
and he's done that
phenomenal job it goes to the senate
they've done a phenomenal job as well
that's why we got hundreds and hundreds
of life appointments of judges
donald trump has not broken any law that
we know of
and he's been here's why i know he
hasn't broken any law
because if he did they would get him on
it
they're desperate to get him on
something
i mean they watch him like a hawk and
they and they create
uh situations the traffic relations to
take him down because
he isn't messing up for real um
peter peter guerrero i think says trump
is a clown
okay so who do you support peter
i wanna know who peter supports because
i have an answer for you
trump's clown is he okay all right
and i think it's interesting to see all
of donald trump's children out there
supporting him
and you can't even find hunter and
ashley anywhere
the biden children they're not
campaigning for their dad
they're not on commercial saying what a
wonderful guy is
you know uh they're they're not out
there trying to pump
up the vote and i know they say oh you
can't bring the kids into it well yeah i
can
because look at donald trump's kids how
proud they are of him
uh how well they've been raised and
they're out there campaigning for their
dad
that is an amazing thing to see
because i mean they are his children but
they these grown adults
and so as eric was here just north of
cincinnati last night
it drew a pretty pretty good sized crowd
liz said i didn't even know biden had a
daughter yeah her name's ashley but you
don't know anything about her because
i mean well except her diary
yeah i mean they just don't have a great
relationship
with their father and it it should speak
volumes to anyone who
is still on the fence at this point if
you are um it should really speak
volumes to you
on these candidates she said
her dad destroyed her life
that's what she said so what nothing to
do with it it's all a shame
and i saw a clip of joe voting yesterday
and his wife and jill voting and the way
that he had to come down those steps
from the courthouse
he had his arm around his wife not like
you're recording her
but as if like a visiting angel was
helping you down the steps
yep and then he reached for her hand and
grabbed her wrist and she tried to pull
away
jill did and grabbed her wrist even
harder and i'm just like oh my
god the weakness he shows to these other
countries
you you you know you you think that it's
all a joke talking about china taking
over
they are just foaming at the mouth they
are just slobbering for a joe
biden presidency yeah
yeah yeah i i mean
i want i voted for president trump in
2016 and i'm going to vote for him again
i didn't i didn't vote for barack obama
either time
either time i voted for john mccain and
i voted for mitt romney
holding your nose and we had to but i
mean i
honestly though those times i really
felt that they could beat barack obama
i mean i i mean i really thought i was
hoping
that mccain and uh witchcock could have
beaten sam the first time
that was kind of rough but i really
thought that mitt had a serious chance
of beating barack the second time and
then pennsylvania came out with the 120
something to
zero it's impossible
bolton and uh you know then i know the
fix was in
in 2016 america got tired
of the politicians they said that they
wanted donald trump
and we and and we did it we did a job we
did it
uh 2020
you got to do it again but this time
but this time you gotta mean it make it
a landslide
yeah that way they have to call it on
election night well there's still 30 000
votes out there but it doesn't matter
because trump
has it by a landslide and those 30 000
votes aren't even going to matter
even if joe got it that's what we want
to hear elect tonight you know there's
30 out there but it's not going to
matter
trump has it it's trump for the win
that's what we need
i don't need you to like donald trump
nico
i don't need you to like biden i don't
need you to like any of that
i need you to care about america law and
order
peace in the middle east better economy
jobs i mean well brian they can't tell
you
why they're voting for biden without
saying trump's name or covet
right yeah well he's just saying i don't
like either one of them i'm like
you don't have to like any of them like
like wayne says you don't like your boss
i know you talk dirt about it behind his
back oh
come on work and take the money
yeah that's sort of a gun he think he
owned his company he does own the
company
he thinks he can tell me what to do he
can
stop working so you guys want to place
bets on
what do you think is going to happen on
tucker tonight that he found them or
that he made copies do you think he's
gonna say he made copies
or that he found them like in a dumpster
somewhere
which one's gonna happen he found the
copies or he has
made the copy that's what i wanna just
want to know what your guys's thoughts
are audience which one i think there's a
third option
tucker found the copies or he has made
the copy
the third one he's not he's gonna
he's not gonna say a word i think his
handlers are looking at this and they're
like
oh god found them wise has made them
wagon fires have found them
he has to say something really
he opened up his damn mouth copies yeah
he's gonna have to say something he
can't just ignore that
i mean he made the biggest deal about it
he opened with it
uh sri estar said he made copies
hey what copies made so he's going to
announce that he made
copies if he claims he's got copies he'd
better produce
or will he claim that he found him no he
was destroyed
he better not get on there and say we
have an update
we're still actively investing
oh don't even tell me we're still
looking we're still looking
and he's gonna fly man no it's not gonna
fly and look and and not say anything
about any copies or anything or that the
original was was back into what you call
it
if he just gets on that yeah yes we do
have an update a quick update
we're still investigating the loss of
the documents we will
update you on anything that we come up
with he could spin it
and er if everybody's saying well he
looks stupid for not making copies he
can come out tonight and say
well i didn't want to tell anybody i
made copies because i was afraid those
copies would go missing too he might
just say that
so that way he doesn't look so stupid i
didn't want to let you know where i kept
the copies under my pillow
somebody said he has copies he sent the
pictures to the courier to show them
what was in the package
i didn't know that in the report he did
say that we sent the courier
image picture i just thought it was
images of the package i just thought it
was images
of the package not what was inside well
but they were looking for what was
inside because they found the package
but they're looking for the documents
i mean you could have pictures of it
and still not have poppies you know
maybe a picture of it
of you putting it in but that still
doesn't mean you have all the copies
it's gonna be an interesting one tonight
i don't know how he's gonna get out
i just figured that they get a phone
call from
helen sugar shack sausage sanctuarium
in delaware saying oh we got a box here
on tv before so oh yeah they're
definitely going to show up some crazy
places there's some pages missing though
but bubulinsky uh steve scully has him
everything that's in there so yeah he
knows it all wayne
he was the ceo he was the guy who's the
head he was the point man
whatever um 31 percent
bush vote did you see something about 31
bush vote
no for black blacks for bush
um no no the highest one was
it goes all the way back to nixon and
that was
in in the teens
i don't know what that was don't you
uh no nixon author the
uh affirmative action oh
he did but democrats call them racist
right and they take get damn republicans
you gotta fight back on this stupid
stuff start calling them races before
they call you racist
you gotta say it first say it often
[Laughter]
leo's like you know what whatever y'all
yeah i was actually just gonna change
the subject to this
did you know joe biden said today that
hunter i'm sorry yesterday that hunter
is the smartest guy he knows
his business dealings hunter's the
smartest guy he knows
well you know you got to give him credit
because hunter's still not arrested he
did all these illegal things and he's
still not in jail that's pretty smart
guy
gotta give him credit there homboy has
disappeared like hunter
i like um tucker's documents
and the two million dollars from or the
nearly three million dollars from the
wisconsin gop
there's a whole lot of things
disappearing these days there is
so you got all that you got hunter
taking a 2.6 million dollar vacation
trying to hide tucker's docks come on
that's crazy all right so let um
this this how we're doing it uh we'll be
back on
monday in my head i was like should we
do a show tomorrow
because it is election weekend but um
i i didn't want to spring that on all my
people so i was like
we will be back on monday uh and
tuesday we're not doing a show at
lunchtime but we are doing the election
show to start to 6 30
right and
depending on how things turn out
tuesday night we'll see what we will be
doing
on wednesday at lunch because um
if it goes into like midnight or
something like that
i'm really not going to turn it around
and jump right back in
i mean we could i mean i got to talk to
them
but i'm you know that's a long night boy
it might go through it might just go
till noon the next day
you don't
i actually had a dream that it went till
november 11th
and the trump was the winner my dream
was trump was the winner but i remember
seeing
11 on the thing and saying it's november
11th and we just found out
trump had won it there was fireworks in
the sky and i said what's going on they
said
didn't you hear the republicans won
trump won and i just remember saying
my gosh it's the 11th of november
i woke up this morning um steve harvey
was talking all this crap about brock
about um donald trump and it was on my
radio
and you know how you hear things while
you sleep yeah
and then it goes into your dreams it
goes into i was fussing with steve
harvey
you need to shut off that urban radio
but
no no because i gotta find out what
they're thinking but um
but i was but i was yelling in
for real outside my sleep
so i'm asleep but i mean yeah i mean i
could hear myself
yeah and i was getting mad because he
wasn't shutting up
and i was like why is he over talking me
and and
he kept talking and talking and talking
like all right well you're gonna stop
you gonna stop because and
i just started talking about anything
and then i woke up i was like oh
crap oh wow too much steve harvey
i was just yelling in the bedroom steve
harvey yeah
so there you go it's like trying to talk
to nancy pelosi
she just came out and said no matter
what
joe biden's going to be president no
matter what
she just said joe biden will be elected
president united states
whatever the election count is on
tuesday
why would she say that whatever the
election count is
oh god's going to get her you can't say
that stuff
you can't say that's not right yeah i
mean i believe in karma
you know i really do and these people
are
well overdue you can't even say that see
that just causes civil unrest
when you say stuff like that yeah that's
not good
well ladies and gentlemen uh we want to
thank all of you for
tuning in to what we have as a show
uh we ask you to contribute to our
patreon
um
yeah you go to patreon yeah dot com
forward slash wd show
from there you can actually choose what
you want to donate
5 10 15 20 25 whole way up you can
donate whatever you would like
and that helps us do the show that helps
travel it also helps us
uh get you the wayne dupree podcast app
as well that you can download and that
app is free so there's a lot of
different uh things that can happen
whenever you don't donate including uh
helping us move forward with the show so
we appreciate that and again here is the
podcast
you can download that and you can watch
us live because we honestly don't know
what's gonna happen with facebook and
twitter
they could up and shut it down just one
day because you know things happen like
so at least you'll be able to still
watch us on uh
the app you can watch old shows you can
also call into the studio when we're
doing that
send us messages and
check your weather and your traffic and
it's all free
because of patreon our patreon helpers
that's right patreon.com forward slash
wd show
any last thought both of you if we did
not forget
to talk about the gdp we just didn't do
it
yes i know 33
33 33. it's the greatest ever
244 years in this country
it turned out to be 33.
keep keep trucking trump there you go
there's another side to it but
you don't want to bring it up we got
time
there's another side to it we just
didn't want to bring it up because then
you'd be like
oh y'all negative
no but just telling y'all all of it
keep it real it's great news
for the election thing
if you can stay away from the whole
story yeah that's all
right so i know president trump is gonna
be talking about it
oh yeah he's already tweeted yeah many
many times yeah i mean
and he's gonna be talking about it uh
for the next couple days
and and the media is gonna be talking
about the other half
i am going to give i'm gonna give my
time
to the audience today instead of my last
thought i'm gonna give my time to the
audience and somebody said before you
sign off can you tell
what each of us what platform you read
comments on
yes we can see what platform you are on
and that we can read comments on and if
you do download the
podcast app you are able to still make
comments because it
will play through the youtube so uh
you'll be able to make comments and
we'll be able to still see them
so there you go i dedicated my time
there we go we got
we have a facebook comment right there
we have a periscope comment right there
we have a youtube comment right here
so basically uh we have we have those
so um and i
manually bring them over um and i know
some of y'all write books
i can't put all that up there
i mean i'm showing you that
but some people put so much more
yeah up there and that would cover the
whole screen so i can't
i can't do that uh make sure you're
sharing the show because we can all see
it
and uh bring your friends on share with
them and you guys can talk amongst each
other
in the show and we can see what you're
saying and bring you on there you go
all right with that said god bless
be kind rewind oh
i don't want to leave
you